except we have mrs. Bieber this is gonna
be controversial I've met her a handful
of times and every time she was not nice
is it too late now to say sorry for
Healy Bieber
I'm trying the model has apologized to a
former New York City restaurant hostess
who recently called her out for
allegedly being not nice so feel like
kind of like awkward about it I'm like
yeah in the viral tick-tock video
Julia Carolyn rated celebrities who she
previously met while working at a fancy
Manhattan restaurant raiding celebrities
I met Waze a hostess in Manhattan part
one and mrs. Bieber didn't exactly make
a good impression I've met her a handful
of times and every time she was not nice
Haley quickly dropped into the comments
section to apologize writing just came
across this video and wanted to say so
sorry if I've ever given you bad vibes
or a bad attitude that's not ever my
intention
[Music]
Justin's wife then owned up to her
mistake writing hate hearing that was
your experience with me but glad you
called me out so I can do better
hopefully we meet again so I can
apologize in person I got you the tick
tock user appreciated Haley's apology
replying to her comment with we love an
accountability Queen thanks so much for
taking the time to apologize I hope we
can meet again one day and start over I
was really impressed
another celebrity who got a low rating
[Music]
yep Kylie's sister Kendall Jenner
the next up we have Kendall Jenner this
is another one where I unfortunately did
not have the best experience with them
she used to come in all the time it was
pretty cold port staff she also usually
has someone speak for her and I can
speak directly to staff I'm gonna give
her the benefit of the doubt and say
she's just shy for my experiences with
her I have to give her like a four out
of ten and sorry Kylie the makeup mogul
received an even lower score for
allegedly being a bad tipper she was
fine but she took $20 on a $500 dinner
bill meanwhile these sisters have got a
perfect rating these two are literally
so nice the user said Gigi and Bella
Hadid were super polite and friendly
with the staff that's a really nice
feeling Nick Jonas got an 8 out of 10 he
came in with his friends one time he was
really normal and chill not too much to
report on this but he definitely seems
like a nice guy and of course the Queen
herself
Beyonce could do no wrong turn in jay-z
Kim and I walk them to their table but
when she loves to make sure to look at
me give me a big smile and say thank you
[Music]